the starting pitcher for the cubs zach
davies the 28 year old right-hander is
out there looking for his seventh
victory here this afternoon against the
royals
in the air shallow right field bode out
hayward in it jason heck of a grab jason
hayward
laying out steals a hit from whit
merrifield
you see bodhi still looking and looking
and eventually jason came on made the
play
ground balls he pulled the change up
schwendell handles the chance to up two
down
out of balance that one collected by
bodhi long throw and they get the
catcher and a good start
for davies brad keller who is making
start number 25 and coming up a start
where he and mike matheny felt like he
had his best two-seam fastball of the
year yeah that's going to help him a lot
salvi warns the right side of the
infield but it's a called third strike
keller begins his afternoon with a
strikeout
very shallow left field
and nikki goes way out benintendi calls
him off and there are two down in the
first inning so one and two on hap
and there's the slider and there's a
strikeout so keller strikes out two to
the second inning we go
santana swings and misses
at the chain jump and a good start for
davies as he's gotten the first four in
a row his first strikeout taylor at the
plate ben and tendy at second here's a
3-2
and a swing and a mix
struck him out
wow
got him looking
davies pitches out of a spot now brad
keller to face patrick wisdom
hey that ball's hit pretty good yeah it
is patrick wisdom forget it
on to wavelength gone
all the way on to waveland avenue a long
home run for patrick wisdom and the cubs
lead it by a score
of one to nothing he got all of that one
home run number 19.
yeah and this one well out of the
ballpark and onto the street
and that brings up the pitcher zach
davies
out of bounce knocked down field but
davies will have a hit so zach with some
good contact pitcher aboard here's
ortega
on the ground the first and it gets
under santana down the line davey's on
his way to third hey and then it gets
past o'hare
but davies will hang on at third and
willie harris putting up the stop sign
let's see if ian happ can come through
hey line drive base hit right field
and this caveat is a two-run single for
hat
does the run score yes yes it does
they slipped around first they tag him
out
it turns out only one run scores on the
base hit by ian half
the right fielder o'hearn threw the ball
to the cutoff man
near first
and that is the first baseman santana
and on the replay run
the umpires
after communicating with new york city
determined that the tag of half occurred
before ortega cross home plate so here's
salvador perez now
there's a fly ball hit pretty well deep
left center field that's gone
over the 368 sign
into the bleachers and the royals are on
the board and salvador perez has his
31st home run of the year very shallow
alleys
very friendly to the hitters and salvi
taking advantage of it right there
with a home run his 31st as he extends
his career high
2-2 to michael a taylor davies
and that is strike three and taylor
frustrated he has struck out twice one
way in the fifth inning rivera the
battery here's the 1-1 and it is hit
high in the air deep to left field
backing up the left-fielder half at the
ivy and that ball is out of here
emanuel rivera with his first major
league home run and the royals have tied
it it was a high arcing shot that barely
cleared
that
wall and left and he's got a big smile
on his face as he receives
congratulations from his teammates
on the ground diving play by wisdom at
third
very nice
steals a hit from merrifield and patrick
wisdom with a heck of a play
royals get a run back and we're starting
over it's 2-2 middle of the fifth
five at wrigley austin romine struck out
his first time up
strike three with a slider and that's
six for keller and the second time he
has gotten romined
check swing and a slider in the dirt
struck him out brad keller now with
seven strikeouts brings up salvi who's
grounded out and hit his 31st homer on
the year and he's going to swing and hit
it high and far down the left field line
way back and gone
he was swinging on 3-0 and the royals
lead it three to two hitch was in on
salvi
but not in enough he kept it fair down
the left field line into the bleachers
royals lead is three to two salvi with
his second homer on the day and his 32nd
home run on the year and ben attendee is
the batter with nobody on a two down and
a swing and a ball hit well deep right
field that's way back and that's gone
make it four home runs for the royals
and they lead it four to two
andrew ben and tendy a double and now a
home run his 12th on the year all four
royals runs coming on solo shots andrew
benintendi got a fastball in and pulled
it over the fence and right
ryan
meisinger comes on in the eighth inning
he'll get the top of the order
jam
way in on his hands duffy throws
not in time and whit has his first hit
nikki gets the bunt down and he is
tagged out by swindell so that'll get
marifield to second and there goes whit
to third and he will be
in there
and the bun is down
and dyson is going to be safe and he'll
get an rbi as wit comes down from third
there you go nice to see dyson
do a little thing with a drag button
like that turns into big thing with an
rbi attached and the hustle the right
the perfect placement then he's able to
beat it out from the mesa so jake jewell
getting the call and the first man he'll
face is cam gallagher and now cam
gallagher cranks one into deep left
field and that is home run number five
for the royals today and cam gallagher
watched nikki lopez finally get his
first yesterday and now he has his first
of the year today why not
season high five home runs
today for the royals how about that so
barlow will come out and pitch the
bottom of the ninth with patrick wisdom
matt duffy and michael hermacillo coming
up and
barlow gets a three-pitch strikeout to
begin the bottom of the ninth
whitt throws in time and there are two
down
and down on strikes to end the game so
it's a come-from-behind win for the
royals down two nothing early the royals
hit
five solo home runs today they also got
a bunt rbi single from dyson